do you feel like you kicked off the
teeth away for a lot of people i know
you was clowning me for that [ __ ]
we're playing a song on the radio but
then i'd have like the horse gift in the
corner
bro where's like like weird started
calling me the mask and [ __ ] just
started like running with this [ __ ] nah
but i i didn't even like it i didn't
even want to get my teeth well your
teeth [ __ ] up no well i didn't want to
get my teeth done i'm one of them people
like prime example right all right shout
out the pun pun is like hey i got this
furniture that i need to go pick up you
feel me so we go to pick up the
furniture this type of guy i am we pick
up the front of the chair and he's like
hey i got an extra one i'm like i want
it i don't even know what the [ __ ] it is
you know what i mean so i get the [ __ ]
he's like do you even know what you
bought i'm like nah i don't know what i
bought i just want that [ __ ] so that's
how i am i ended up going to this place
i happened to be there traveling
my homeboy wherever it was my homeboy
was getting his teeth done and it was
like hey
we know you we could do your [ __ ] too i
was like let's do it and i ran with that
[ __ ] that's the weirdest thing is like
i'll never notice like most people who
get the new teeth i don't notice they
ever had bad teeth for the most part
there's a few people
who i'm like yeah you needed that but
most of the time i'm like what i never
noticed anything was wrong with your
teeth my [ __ ] wasn't like
it wasn't like it was but i noticed when
you have them [ __ ] chompers you know
what i'm saying this is nice though but
look it was funny though because i i did
uh um
snoops uh the ggn news right yeah and
somebody wrote back was like hey these
teeth was [ __ ] up and i kind of like
made fun of myself and screenshotted but
my teeth went bad it was more on the
yellowish side you know i'm saying a
little tainted
but yeah i'm perfect it's called being
an adult you know what i'm saying now
[ __ ] that [ __ ] when the hair go i'm i'm
getting the full treatment too maybe
everything's fake i'm gonna have
everything bro we gotta strike back now
the beard ain't fake this [ __ ]
that people are thinking about being
here you know i got [ __ ] weird fake
beard